how's it going oh no questions okay
thanks guys
see you later George I have seen your
mother by your side a lot through this
now we need to tell me about this
strength that she brings you to this
incredible experience what a nice
question to start with I you know we
were we were born very poor you know
into pretty humble surroundings and my
mother always wanted to do something
better with her life she wanted to do
something better for her children as she
was a dreamer she was a worker she still
is and so I think the biggest
inspiration the biggest lessons she
taught me was to dream and then to do
the work that it takes to make dreams a
reality so it's been fun to bring her
around and you know you get these
opportunities to stand up here and say
something that the best part is to be
able to thank the people that have
believed in you for so long and of
course you know I could spend every
single one of these events thanking my
mother and talking about my mom she's
the best yeah
I'm Lindsay with liquid style first off
I love your sparkly shoes oh thank you
yes where the effort this is my question
but what inspired you to wear those you
know I just saw them I don't dress up
very much you know so so I don't know I
just saw them and I thought it'd be fun
you got up fun with all right you know
you want to and you also want to I don't
wear a lot of suits and sports jackets
but you want to feel like yourself not
like your agent sorry Mick Jim you said
that you don't want to ever lose weight
for a role would you ever gain weight
for a role and why why well you know
it's a good question whatever gain
weight for all I gained 67 pounds for a
little film that obviously you didn't
see called chapter 27 but you know my
mom my brother saw it that's about it
but no I would never do that again
because it's really it's really brutal
it's not it's not a lot of fun
and it's really bad for your your body
and you know maybe I would lose a little
weight you know but not like I did
before and I certainly would never gain
weight again for a role remind me of
that please if I ever start the process
Jared more noble from Access holiday um
I was the Santa Barbara Film Festival
when you had out running with a heckler
in the audience and I know this film is
kind of a unlearning to show people
compassion sure you had a meeting with
that person backstage how did that go
all it was it was great I thought it was
wonderful
I think hecklers a bad term you know I
mean really it was a debater you know
someone who felt like they needed to
take a moment to public moment and to
say something that that something that
was on their mind something that meant
something to them so I'm a believer in
the debate I think it's healthy I think
it's positive certainly you know it's
not like I can't learn something I got
plenty to learn so somebody has an
opinion or idea a well-thought-out one
I'm all ears so we had a nice really
nice cordial talk
and I think you know it the planets
better for those those kinds of
interactions you know oh thank you
that's it what a tease